ce boulanger au bord des larmes a reçu
comme tous les commerçants artisans de
notre pays le courrier de trop de la
part d'EDF le 14 novembre dernier ce
courrier annonçait une hausse
exorbitante des prix de 322%. 322%
madame la Première ministre c'est simple
sur une facture annuelle certains
passeront pour l'année 2023 de 16000
euros à 40000 euros que répondre à ces
fans et ces hommes qui se battent au
quotidien pour survivre eux qui ont déjà
tant souffert durant la crise sanitaire
et qui pour la plupart ont investi
toutes leurs économies dans leur passion
mais au-delà de cette terrible réalité
qui touche bien trop de nos concitoyens
c'est l'avenir du commerce et de
l'artisanat en France qui est en jeu
votre gouvernement s'est été saisi bien
trop tard de ce problème elle est
dispositifs se succèdent mais ils sont
souvent
inefficaces inadaptées et ils font
beaucoup d'oublier de nombreux artisans
madame la Première ministre depuis
plusieurs semaines et sur ces bancs nous
avons été très nombreux à vous le dire
vous lance un appel au secours ces
personnes qui ne se plaignent jamais se
sont toujours acquittés de leurs tâches
avec rigueur acharnement et traumatisme
car ils ont la France chevillé au corps
cette crise nous permet malheureusement
de vous rappeler que oui oui nos
artisans contribuent à Laura de notre
pays ils sont les dernières
représentants d'un savoir-faire de nos
territoires et font vivre chaque jour
notre économie locale alors pourquoi
continuer d'indexer le prix
d'électricité sur celui du gaz et
au-delà
de ses professionnels dans leur
quotidien de façon pérenne sans en
laisser sur le bord du chemin je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]